[Music]
all right
it is now time to show you and talk to
you
about that viral dog lady central park
video
you made it so exciting it was exciting
i thought we were gonna like play a game
i know you built it up so
let's get reminded of racism
i didn't mean to sound excited i just
you haven't seen it
i guess that was kind of because you
guys were asking about it so like
you know i was like it's now time i'm
ready okay here we go
drum roll please yeah somebody here is
going in the car
what's the estimated retail price the
most
anticipated video of 2020. like feeling
the
the growth of anticipation
the racist racism [ __ ] video
we're like karen good [ __ ] yeah karen
chucking her dog
let's do it karen choked her dog i saw
this it's sad
let's do it because the the dog was a
dark you're about to watch it
what what because you said it was a
racism video so i thought it was like
let's do it with the dog towards the dog
he was a dark dog no it was a white dog
he was a white poodle
no oh you guys said it was a racist
video
it is you're gonna see why all right
yeah you'll see okay back story
is this man this black man
was in central park bird watching he's
an avid bird watching no such thing as
what she said
already outright i don't know any black
man that watches birds that's right
so white man sports i never heard of
something i just learned from from this
whole
uh situation that they're called birders
they're called ornithologists i thought
they're called like arbor versus
ornithology ornithologist
he's a part of the arbor he made that up
i don't know i didn't made that up
sometimes it sucks to be here
[Laughter]
it's like as soon as you say a word
we're like no no
that doesn't make our nine brains versus
your brain says no that i'm like
all right it's not an orthologist though
it's fake
what is it falling forward or
mythologist it's the study of bird it's
bird watching
orny mm-hmm
okay and those are the kind of jokes we
got here that's all i got
a bunch of people in the comments like
stupid geo of course it's real
i know [ __ ] well they probably googled
it to like
who wants to know about ornithologists
like nerd you [ __ ]
because i love james bond and james bond
was named after
a book about birds that was written by
an ornithologist named
james bond really yes the title for
james bond
was taken from them that sounds geeky
that sounds serious but they're they're
part of a society called the arborville
ibm
society yeah arboretum yeah r a r b
o r b o r b i can't pronounce
okay well anyway it starts with that a
and a u and the rest of the
things blur out in my eyes and bore four
times there we go back to filling in
people like bart who has no idea what
the story is and giving you some
backstory so again he was there bird
watching
ornithologist yes that and then that's
when he noticed
this woman there with her dog without
the dog on a leash which
apparently this part of central park
called the ramble
is um it has a whole bunch of signs
everywhere saying that you must have
your dog on a leash in this particular
area
and so that's when christian he walked
up to her and said like hey
this is actually the what went down
before the video so
he wrote this down on facebook it says
central park this morning this woman's
dog is
tearing through the plantings in the
ramble me ma'am dogs in the ramble have
to be on the leash at all times
the sign is right there her the dog the
dog runs are closed he needs his
exercise
me all you have to do is take him to the
other side of the drive
outside the ramble and you can let him
run off leash all you want
her it's too dangerous me look if you're
gonna do what you want
i'm gonna do what i want but you're not
gonna like it her
what's that me to dog come here puppy
her he won't come to you me we'll see
about that
i pull out the dog treats i carry for
just the
in transcendence for such and
transcendence
i didn't even get a chance to toss any
treats to the pooch before karen
scrambled to grab the dog
her don't touch my dog that's when i
started video recording with my iphone
and when her inner karen
fully emerged and took a dark turn so
now we're gonna watch the video
he tried to carry her she's like you're
not gonna out carry to me yeah they
carried each other a little bit
he was like you know what i'm gonna feed
your [ __ ] dog treats oh i carry these
for such entrance intentions
a nerd i know right but he's like if
you've seen him he's a [ __ ] like he's
like a sexy ass nerd
i'll show you a photo of him right now
okay yeah yeah he's
yeah here we go what what's happening
sorry i'm asking you to stop there we go
please don't look at the poor dog
sir i'm asking you to stop recording
please don't come closer please take
your phone off please don't come closer
please please call the cops please call
the clubs
i'm going to tell them there's an
african-american man threatening my life
please tell him what it'd be like
she actually said that that's the part
i mean we all know that a lot of people
recognize that [ __ ] for sure but watch
look at this i can't watch it oh
whoa that kind of [ __ ] gets people
killed
is pretending she's getting hurt
yeah that's some [ __ ] dude exactly
thank you so as soon as she leashes her
dog
right that's where he goes thank you so
then the cops did
show up oh no um but there were no
arrests okay or anything
no one got detained because he had
already left by that okay but
so the reason why this went uh public
was because
christian's sister tweeted out this
video and captioned it with
oh when parents take a walk with their
dogs off leash in the famous
bramble in ny's central park
where it is clearly posted on signs that
dogs must be leashed at all times and
someone like my brother
parentheses and avid birder politely
asks her
to put her dog on leash so that went
viral to the point where uh amy
amy cooper which is funny because they
both have the same last name but they
don't have any relation
um the amy's employer
immediately like tweeted out um they
said we take these matters
very seriously and we do not condone
racism of any kind while we are in the
process of investigating the situation
the employee involved has been put on
administrative leave they actually fired
her i was about to say oh as
of now she has actually been fighting
yeah but we don't know that she's a
racist just because her dog is named
aryan cutie
aryan doesn't mean that she's racist
she's like come on erin kitty
come on hey kitty hate all right
so then um the shelter where she got
this dog from
they posted this on facebook that doggy
was choking yeah she said
thank you to the concerned public for
reaching out to us about a video
involving a dog that was adopted from
our rescue a few years ago
as of this evening the owner has
voluntarily surrendered the dog in
question to our rescue while this matter
is being addressed our mission remains
the
the health and safety of our rescued
dogs the dog is now in our rescues care
and he is safe and in good health we
will not be responding to any further
inquiries
yeah you guys this is christian
okay i see what you guys are talking
about
is somebody who studies this [ __ ] he's
inverter he's a [ __ ] hobby guy yeah
orny as [ __ ]
he's all professional i guess he's not a
pigeon
that's a pigeon that's another pigeon
central park
oh that's a white dove
that's okay do you think he goes through
his camera and he deletes all the pigs
and [ __ ] he's like somebody pigeons
yo man i made friends with the bluebird
that's my favorite
bird he always comes visits me let's
talk about that at your house
how do you know you guys are friends
because he always says what's up
how cuz oh no he comes over he's like
what that dude
yeah and then he goes up and he comes
back
same time as soon as i'm done with my
workout i sit on my [ __ ]
little lawn chair i'm just how big is he
he's like this big
oh and he goes what's up guy what's up
dude and then he goes away
do you feed him anything yeah do you i
should huh i'll leave some [ __ ] for him
my mom swears that our uncle bob who
died
of aids thanks for asking everybody
[ __ ] [ __ ] um
don't stop making me laugh at that no
that though that he always says it like
you know that he comes via crow
like so every time there's a crow
they're calling at us my mom's like
hey uncle bob like it's always like that
why a crow why not a sparrow or
something
a lot of people believe that crows are
like reincarnated why
crows because they're creepy oh pros are
not creepy
they are green you know the difference
between a raven and a crow no what is it
no
no i don't it's just a little bit bigger
that's it oh i mean i'm sure this is a
higher class oh dude you're fat shaming
do you remember a kyoto i don't mean
i don't mean wider or fatter i'm just
saying bigger in size
you guys do you guys remember in kyoto
like well you guys were walking taika
like early as [ __ ] right
yeah so they don't have pigeons and [ __ ]
picking in the trash they have
[ __ ] crows this big we were out
looking for food yeah it was crazy it
was
oh my god there's some skeletal [ __ ] man
i love really i've never seen a bird
this [ __ ] big picking at trash cans
i was like scared to go shoot i just
[ __ ] when i'm sorry
so what's bigger the crows are the
ravens ravens and they have like super
sharp
beaks too right that's nice and scary
never mind so this is the cat
nice reference she looks completely
different oh she looked crazy
that's a cute she was crazy her name is
amy by the way
and it's funny because after this most
recent karen situation all the real life
karen's are like we're not all like this
well of course you are i have an aunt
karen i'm sorry
my cousin named karen my first got it
because she
doesn't matter my first girlfriend ever
was karen davis
when i was 14. yeah shout out to karen
davis was [ __ ] karen
she was tattletailed outside oh no she
was cool
you fingered me i'm telling my mother
that you fingered me oh my god
you tried to i never fingered karen
davis i was in seventh grade
okay good i follow a page called karen's
gone wild and it's pretty [ __ ] crazy
there's this one karen i can't she's
basically uh uh she was like what do you
call it um those park ranger karen's
right
and this dude he accidentally went into
the wrong road and he was making a
u-turn
and that [ __ ] stood in front of the car
like this and she says stop
get out of the vehicle and he goes lady
i just made a wrong turn i'm
getting out of here and then she started
screaming and calling the police
like he's running over dude
yeah [ __ ] aggressive like middle-aged
white women
are the scariest ones like this one in
the video yeah
no remember that an african-american man
that's trying to kill me why do they oh
why didn't karen's always sound like
they're drowning too
i just want to say
like it's like god damn remember the one
from the bay with the barbecue and how
she was like crying
yeah [ __ ] i forgot what happened but
robo karen
when i was 19 i just got my driver's
license i was getting karen's
in a cul-de-sac yeah by an old man
who i called kevin's i was in kevin's i
was all the way across the street
pulling into a driveway
and he was walking with his little
[ __ ] whoever god knows what the god
son
or some [ __ ] all the way to the mailbox
completely across the street
i pulled into the driveway he comes up
to my car knocks on the window and he's
like
do you know that i'm walking with my god
son over here
and like it is he created a dangerous
situation i'm like brother i was
all the way the [ __ ] across the street
like what world are you in like
what what's happening here in the world
just don't have any control in their
life so they need to
place their control and assert their
aggressiveness on other people because
they feel so
small themselves you're right man oh my
goodness it's pretty
[ __ ] scary the fact that her first
instinct was to be like
an african-american man threatening my
life
because she was like you know because
she knew what she was doing right and
then she didn't say n-word
yeah i mean that's true good for her but
it's like but like she knew what she was
doing to
she knew yeah she's like you're leading
the system to be a
victim because she was like hey just so
you know this is what i'm gonna do
african-american man is starting my life
right now
watch what's gonna happen you know dude
that's crazy she weaponized that [ __ ]
let's just say he's a fan of the nets
yeah noah let me just wrap this up with
her
response to all this so she ended up
being interviewed
what's her excuse now and so this is her
statement i was scared because he was so
black
so she said i sincerely and humbly
apologize to everyone especially to that
man
his family it was unacceptable and i
humbly and fully apologize to everyone
who's seen that video everyone that's
been offended everyone who thinks of me
in a lower light and i understand why
they do when i think about the police
i am such a blessed person i have come
to realize especially today that i think
of
the police as a protection agency and
unfortunately this has caused
me to realize that there are so many
people in this country that don't have
that luxury
oh what the [ __ ] does that all mean
she's like and i just want to apologize
to that man that black man that midnight
black man like 12 30 black man
i'm just so sorry really he was more of
like a
7 30 p.m black yeah he's like a
hershey's chocolate
wasn't he more like a sunset black man
yeah i think so sweet
okay well damn
[Music]
[Music]
do